what did you think of the Wisconsin
primaries and how it turned out well
actually I mean it wasn't a huge
surprise I mean you know we didn't think
that Trump was going to win this one
Bernie Sanders has spent a ton of money
in Wisconsin and this was again a much
more of a component of voter that that
has always gone for him in the past he's
won a big rush of states but he still he
has still hasn't caught up to Hillary
and it just shows that she's going to
have to just slug it out just hug it out
to the bitter end on the delegate votes
and hope that at some point and I think
it will come the value of experience is
going to finally be understood because
what we're seeing with Bernie Sanders is
he's appealing to young people mostly
because what he says can't be done you
know he he mean it can't be a common I
mean you can't just declare we're going
to pay for every kid to go to college
free we're going to have everybody have
health care free we're going to have you
know break up the big banks we're
starting to be are asking him now and he
felt very badly in that Daily News
interview well how you gonna do it pony
like just take a second specifics it
that you are hearing questions like that
to trump as well absolutely when these
guys finally can stop the hot air
balloons and get asked questions about
how you're going to do it people start
to think wait a minute he sounds like
the boss who walks in a bit says I'm
gonna do it and hasn't got a clue house
you know however how come Hillary
Clinton you know people say Hillary
Clinton's got a women a woman vote
problem that she's popular among women
over the age of 65 but younger than that
she's having a hard time coalescing them
why well first of all I think it is a
young issue and I think that young woman
in that sense it's good young women and
young men think the same way right the
young people like his message I there's
a lot to like about his message because
it sounds so kind of block the world out
of the box you know occupy wall so young
people are smarter yeah they are but i
also think we young people love to feel
that things can be done and that's what
the great thing is about being young I
think you know listen I know a ton of
young women who love Hillary Clinton and
in my daughter's 24 and all of her
friends are crazy about Hillary Clinton
fact they're giving fundraise of Hillary
Clinton and they think she's a really
cool power she's going to be in trouble
here in New York I think she'll win New
York I do think she'll win Neil because
I think she has her the question is by
how much right now by how much yes but
she and a win is a win is a win as we
know so I do think she'll win in you but
you know I think her campaign has had a
tough
time it's been a hard slog and I think
it's frustrating for her and not just to
be able to focus at this point on the
Republicans because that is such a
meltdown such a shock well and that's
the problem she's been having to fend
off for anything when a why hasn't she
been able to put him away at this point
but Tina let's let's move to your your
roots your homeland the UK and you
mentioned brexit right so there were
only a few months away where do you
stand on whether whether the UK should
stay or not stay in the EU well I think
we should stay in the EU because I think
that you know sharing intelligence is
enormously important i think that the
decision to to go back into kind of
little england is not viable in the
world of today i mean you can pretend
that globalism you know is something you
can sort of remove yourself from but
actually i don't think it is i think
that that ship has sailed so I'm a big
big favor of staying but I don't think
it's good on then why is the public so
split on this well because you know
quite honestly I think people just are
in the mood to just reject the same way
that you know that that Scotland wanted
to suddenly go independent there's a
sense that big stuff is just slows you
up and I on again I understand that
feeling it's true when you're in any
kind of corporate situation the big
takeover happens and suddenly all the
energy goes out of there or the status
quo task laughs it's not enough and I
think there's a huge amount of
bureaucracy about Europe I think that
it's slow stuff up i think that it makes
everybody feel that there's this big
sort of Bigfoot over them but at the
same time i don't think that isolation
is a 21st century position that can you
know is viable